para poner calambre por favor él hizo un
día de las indicaciones para el ensayo
final es el líder de una agrupación de
18 bailarines que interpretan las
tradiciones indígenas a través de la
danza crea un refugio seguro para la
comunidad el gp y con más de la que
también forma parte se visten de mujer
mientras se apropian de la cosmovisión
andina bailan por el reconocimiento y la
aceptación social porque sentimos que
habiendo tanta riqueza en nuestro país
tanta identidad cultural tantos
personajes nuestros pueblos indígenas
que están vivos que son parte que son
latente que es un gran porcentaje de
nuestro país entonces nosotros lo
queremos tomar como parte ya que es tan
nuestro para identificar y para
visibilizar a nuestra comunidad help etb
y con más comunidad donde roberto calero
encontró refugio hace 7 años luego que
su familia los rechazará por su
orientación sexual con la ayuda de
edinson hoy se transforma entre máscaras
y atuendos folclóricos para hacer
realidad su sueño de bailar es un
refugio y también es mi pasión
siempre he anhelado en bailar en algún
grupo muy importante y hoy por hoy puedo
decir que estoy muy contento muy feliz y
muy realizado al realizar este arte
transformista mediante la danza
en ecuador 70% de la comunidad el gti
cumpas aseguró haber sido rechazada por
su orientación sexual también han
sufrido de actos de violencia amenazas o
detenciones arbitrarias según datos del
instituto nacional de estadística ine
el rechazo la comunidad sexo diversa ha
logrado que personas heterosexuales como
pablo carvajal se unen a este grupo de
danza con el fin de dar apoyo a la
diversidad yo lo estoy ayudando a
maquillar pero también los estoy
acompañando en escenarios enfrentando a
la crítica que a veces es un poco dura
entre la comunidad y de la sociedad
hacia ellos
estos bailarines no se rendirán ante el
objetivo de educar sobre la
discriminación arraigada en un país
donde ya se reconoce la identidad género
y el matrimonio entre parejas del mismo
sexo
[Música]